Святогірськ, що на півночі Донецької області - один із небагатьох курортів Донбасу.
До війни люди приїжджали сюди на вихідні відпочити або помолитися у Святогірській лаврі -
чоловічому монастирі на березі Сіверського Донця.
З початком бойових дій цей монастир став також прихистком для численних біженців.
Дехто з них проживає тут і досі. 37-річна Альона Кулєшова у монастирі з 2014-го року.
З рідного Донецька вона разом із родиною втекла ще на початку війни - боялася за дітей.
До нашого будинку підвезли - навіть не знаю, як це правильно називається - гаубицю, здається.
Кілька днів стріляли. Ми недовго потерпіли і поїхали.
Це була якась маячня, в яку дуже довго не вірилось.
Навіть коли ми вже були тут, мені довго в це не вірилось.
Альона каже, що сподівалась невдовзі повернутися. Тож, речей із собою майже не брала.
Про мирне життя у довоєнному Донецьку, де у неї була власна квартира і дрібний бізнес,
жінці сьогодні нагадують лише декілька фотографій.
Бачите - це вид з мого вікна, а це - моя кухня вдома.
На відміну від донецької квартири, у кімнаті Альони у готелі для паломників при монастирі кухні немає.
Тут вона живе з двома синами-підлітками і маленькою донькою.
Втім, жінка вдячна і за цей прихисток. За її словами, без допомоги монастиря не вижила б.
За кімнату Альона не платить. Їжу також отримує безкоштовно.
Каже, що працювати поки не може.
Адже через родинні обставини сама піклується про трирічну доньку Марію.
У монастирі біженці допомагають один одному, турбуються про них і ченці.
Особлива увага - дітям.
Адже багато хто з них пережив психологічну травму під час обстрілів і втечі.
Тож, такі заходи - не просто розвага, а, насамперед, психологічна допомога.
Монахиня Арсенія опікується біженцями, які живуть у монастирі, з початку війни.
Каже, найважче було під час боїв за Слов’янськ, Дебальцеве, ескалації в Авдіївці.
У найважчі часи монастир одночасно давав прихисток понад тисячі біженців.
Виживали завдяки пожертвам і волонтерській допомозі.
Звичайно, тоді було важче.
Вони по декілька місяців були у бомбосховищах - приїжджали брудні, закопчені.
В однієї бабусі, що до нас приїхала, опариші були у п’ятці.
Ми організували санпункт у нас в корпусі, де ми людей перевдягали, прали їм одяг,
міряли тиск, ставили крапельниці, надавали всіляку допомогу.
Сьогодні у монастирі залишилось приблизно 170 біженців. Майже стільки ж, як і ченців.
Більшість переселенців - літні, самотні люди та багатодітні матері.
Об’єднує всіх їх одне - мрія про кінець війни.
Звичайно, хочеться, щоб був мир. Щоб була можливість виховувати дітей.
Щоб у них було повноцінне харчування. Щоб можна було водити їх на гуртки і їздити відпочивати.
Ці речі, які раніше були для нас звичайними, тепер починаєш цінувати.
Великі надії Альона, як і багато хто на Донбасі, покладає на нову владу.
Вірить, що президенту Зеленському вдасться закінчити війну, а їй - повернутися в Донецьк.
Втім, на виборах біженка так і не проголосувала -
каже, не знайшла грошей на дорогу до виборчої дільниці в сусідньому місті.